hey hey hey hey hey hey hey where are
you oh my gosh why is my camera's like
all dude ah hey Don it's Mike I'm so
busy but I do have to do
Tatia Tatia cover for Quinn this
obviously is not it but I really think
I'm gonna do something not too
dissimilar from this for the Tatia cover
sorry for those who didn't see this
there's the layers layers this was the
cover for the latest issue of Game of
Thrones Clash of Kings and I like the
way this looks and you know me I really
like to do covers that are kind of like
movie movie poster Drew Struzan II kind
of design he covers but Weldon and Kanan
already did covers that are like that so
I was really thinking well suck quit
what is up to you let me get my ID what
is up so I was thinking of doing
something more along the lines of just a
great big face and then maybe doing some
some skirting it with some other stuff
going on like maybe the the witches in
the woods kind of like at the bottom but
the whole Matt and Keenan kind of went
in and designed the way I usually design
covers so I don't want to just do a
third mm-hmm movie poster rest kind of
cover so I was thinking about that and
there's my cat wants to see max oh boy
don't good boy max hey get off I can't
see max is your camera on I can't see it
uh yeah but are you what do you what are
you looking at you're on stream yard
right yeah I'm on stream yard but like
your thing is just
but my I don't know it really hello
about now yeah the whole screen is just
gray but I can see your black just
blacklist you'll believe in Heroes again
really there's like a little half of
something right at the bottom yeah it's
weird if it likes it on YouTube let me
know let me go look on YouTube it might
just be me cuz I know my leg that's on
audio only oh there you go I see you
know oh right on right on
well that'll work them alright I mean
close the door system noises ah
Quinn Quinn oh my that's something on my
end anyway why did you only give me six
months to do this I thought six months
all right I'm just happy that you're
drawing one you can cover so sick I know
like Jesus Christ when I saw that I was
like dude holy crap yeah I think I'm so
excited I can't believe it's finally
happening I'm gonna tweet this out and
post it on YouTube share it on your
shirt on your YouTube that's where
you're affected what I was my own write
off everybody everyone banners like
ensure please don't come in here making
all the boys I'm screaming like I forgot
what it was like just other records no
it can get a little manic at times so
you haven't been on for a while don't
you catch everybody up on where where
you been what you're up to I mean
obviously tomorrow is the big day
yes prepping my audience to make sure
they all all back you on the first day
so
excellent excellent guys well yeah so
we've been working on getting Tatia
ready and getting the campaign ready to
launch tomorrow
I personally have been moving I moved
literally all the way across the country
some like in like a very short span of
time was very sudden from like Georgia
to Northern California so that's
something that's been going on during
the process of trying to get this
graphic novel ready and introduced to
the world yeah so we got we have we've
had Canaan white draw a cover and
Matthew Walton is tires the tires
Tyler tirelessly working and Mike is
just about to start his and I'm about to
tweet and post about it you want to do
kind of a similar look that
unless you have an idea for what I like
the concept that you were describing
initially to me yeah at the faith
because I want to do those Kurt you know
me and my curls Matt oh man I designed a
character with so many curls I dig the
curls man when you drew that first
concept picture Tatia with all the curls
I was like yeah that was great
let's see okay I'll take this picture
right here
Quinn's volume is low well I volume is
low how is that guys hey there you go
that's not yeah yeah so pardon me guys
if I seem distracted I'm just letting
everybody know that I'm streaming over
here on the blacklist Universe Channel
okay
right Gloria says congratulations on a
successful move
thank you so much it was definitely
stressful
wait but you're not done yet right did
you did you find a permit we haven't we
still haven't found a permanent
permanent place yet but we are kind of
like settled in a house in a short-term
rental and where did you find a roommate
did he move with you or was my roommate
yes
thank you from Lucifer means light
bringer oh really so he lets you go
yeah we decided we both wanted to move
at the same time till we figure it like
why not let's be roommates for like a
year
yeah that was weird because I was like
remain if no one else listening you talk
about Game of Thrones and it's like was
it he found a roommate who knows I'm
roommates with another game of Thrones
youtuber yeah nice well it'll be much
easier for you to make videos together
now wait do you are you guys gonna just
have one studio or are you gonna do have
two studios in the house to record well
yeah we're gonna have we're definitely
gonna have separate spaces but we were
like definitely conceptualizing like a
singular studio for like that both of us
can use as well I think you should just
get a green screen and then you can just
both have different group different
backgrounds yeah I really do have a
green screen and I've been utilizing it
recently and some of my video since been
working pretty good yeah I just started
using the green screen stuff yeah the
Tarija update is in the chat and it is
in the description so please do get over
there and sign up watch tomorrow are you
gonna do this special tear for for the
mailing list it's there yeah they hope
discounts yeah you can get a discount on
the sign hardcover and a discount on the
signed paperback so it's yeah there's
secret tears they are secret tears it's
90 percent off of the paperback and you
can get 50% off the sign hardcover nice
but you have to you have to sign up
the mailing list to get the link to the
secret tears so that no you have to do
that before we launch mm all right sorry
my image disappeared here
how close Weldon is being he seems to
have given her a little younger around
her face was that hmm suggested by you
or was that just him no that was his
interpretation which I don't mind it's
just yeah I'm already liking what I'm
saying Mike she's it's Sinead O'Connor
bald yeah so did you get any uh have you
talked to anybody else like um Prairie
or anybody about gray area might be
coming on yeah ice might like dr. area
so she says she's going to support me in
any way
wait she's a good friend of mine
actually so yeah I can pretty much ever
on at any time she's super super cool we
love grey area yeah I've only ever
talked to her in DM so I've never we
still never been on a stream I don't
think she's super nice she's super super
nice cool she's a fire breather on
Twitter about she's super nice I'm
speaking of Twitter let me post a link
to Twitter now that I have posted it to
youtube please and then I have no idea
what's going on with green and green
hand yeah yeah I don't know gone back
and forth on we're done we're not
streaming any more together and then
next time I turn it on there to get
they're just coming together I'm like
hiding for Donna cover life yeah I have
no idea I tried to talk to Mary Ellen
the other day but I think she was like
super busy on something she couldn't get
back to me
sup Dave on his channel yep it's Dave in
the background we'll just call him
background D alright so let me now uh I
forget what color are her eyes do I
specifically say they're like dark brown
dark dark okay cool yeah I didn't give
her like crazy looking eyes or anything
thanks buddy
unlike mother Silas who has silver eyes
for very specific reason which I'm not
really full of silver I don't think
that's it if you cut her she'd just
bleed silver oh where was that somebody
there was a movie with the character who
bled silver was it Wolverine I know you
have like the adamantium no no I
remember there's there's a scene in like
X in one of the movies where he's like
fighting lady Deathstroke and like he
puts the adamantium in her life face and
like right yeah that's that he
overloaded her without a man Geum yeah I
remember that scene from when I was a
weak boy so funny
I forget man you you're young enough to
meet my kid yeah I'm oh I just turned 26
cos I'm a little bit older than last
time she's [ __ ] we spoke 26 really
yes I am 26 for some reason I thought
you turn like 24 no I'm not quite that
young yeah
I forget dude I'm reward okay Oh while
we're here tell tell the audience all
about Tatia as much as you can away as
soon as I hit Send on this tweet all
right now you can give it a minute and
then join us for the stream be here of
east square or peoples erst
no I'm kidding you can be right good so
yeah yeah
Oh Mike that looks so good so far so
yeah Tatia is the story of a young girl
who is caught in between this whole
thing between this coven of witches and
this King guy that's toddy at the end no
I'm kidding no seriously though Talia is
a horror fantasy graphic novel that is
inspired by many different things I've
taken various elements from real world
mythology switch them up change them in
various places to help them fit my story
so there's a lot of like names that you
might recognize like Bale or the foam or
a Hakata goddesses and spirits and all
sorts of stuff from the real world
that's been altered slightly like I said
for the story and it is a story about a
coven of witches who have a several
decades long plan to restore the balance
of maratha they say but it is really
them shaping or at least attempting to
shape the kingdom and them in the way
they see fit
alright and so their whole plan is to
create Tatia for a specific goal and
that specific goal
I have talked about this previously but
I'm kind of shying away talking about
what it is specifically so yeah I'll let
that be revealed well the whole thing is
they've gone to great extremes to create
Tatia this girl Talia to the point where
they don't even fully know if they will
be able to ultimately control her and
they don't even fully realize the or
fully comprehend the magic that they use
to create her and so that's what's going
on
there's AI like yeah I like that by the
way because that's it's kind of a an
issue I have with Star Wars is that is
that everyone you know the Jedi think
they know what the force is
and the SIF think they know what the
fourth it forces but to me it's like
these are just these are guys grasping
at straws trying to you know understand
essentially a force of nature absolutely
right but it's so beyond their
understanding that they're they're like
they have these these to me it's like
the force is is the light side because
of how you're using it and then the
force is the dark side because of how
they're using it and it's not it's not
in and of itself something that has its
own will so it's just being tapped into
sort of like what you're talking about
yeah all right and I guess I can get
into some of the tangental elements of
Tatia that aren't like necessarily
straight-up
revealed or like mentioned in the first
book well so basically I set up this
kind of mythology so there was three
kind of I would just call them heavenly
aspects there's Bale or who is
consumption darkness and then there is
who caught a fire like you get that
dichotomy and then there is the other
we'll talk about that guy later but
basically these three aspects existed at
the beginning of time and the mortal
realm is the realm of Hakata which Bale
or has invaded and is beginning to
and there have been various people that
have worshiped bail or had several
points in history in fact I mentioned in
Tatia which this is all this this story
also has the potential to be like maybe
a spin-off backstory at some point
there's in Elden where Tatia grew up
there's like the mines the mountain
range that surrounds it and it says in
Tatia that it wasn't always called Eldon
and that there were people that were
here way before this place was even
settled so there was people that lived
in those mountains that call themselves
the warlocks of them help or at least
they recalled the war lots of the
mountain there's all sorts of legends
about those guys but basically they were
worshippers of bail or in a long time
ago it went wrong and it corrupted those
minds forever so there's all sorts of
bad things that goes on in the minds and
happens so people tend to there's all
sorts of stories that come out of those
minds and right so that's one so yeah
like I was saying but yeah I was talking
about like maybe going back and doing a
back story and explaining more about it
so the way I was like conceptualizing it
is just like the daughters of a caught a
who kind of like tap into the power of
this goddess Hecate and try and bend it
and use it for their own little these
warlocks of the mountain guys basically
didn't say did the same thing with bail
or and you see the thing that I'm doing
by putting this backdrop in here and
saying that you have these people that
worshiped one of these aspects one of
these God beings and it went horribly
wrong and now you have that happening
again so is it gonna go horribly wrong
this time so that's basically what I'm
setting up there by mentioning that
element tangent totally mmm yeah that's
what's going on sorry you just let me
into another end sorry while you think
of things I just go into train of
thought for so it reminds me of like so
I I know it's not fact or or it's just
sort of a theory but i pr i--'s that
like a lot of the gods of old are
actually Nephilim mmm-hmm
yeah yeah well I mean Nephilim yeah the
name is from the Bible and and their
their cross
breed of angels and demons or angels and
man but you know the Bible says that
they were the the mighty men of renown
and the heroes of old and you kind of
get these similar characters you know
from the Norse to the Greeks - well I'm
gonna say the Russians but the Russians
are really Old Norse gods but it's where
you you know you have humans having
having either either mythified their
stories or or actually they were
worshipped as gods in the time they were
actually around mm-hmm
you know so it's it's it's fun because
it's it's a history that you're not
gonna know for sure but it's fun if like
you went back in time and you like you
played around with with what the history
was because because nobody knows nobody
can tell you were you were wrong and
you're making a fiction out of it
anyways so mm-hmm did what you were
saying was just kind of reminding you
that absolutely yeah I am just kind of
playing with that and but like within my
own kind of like fictionalized universe
absolutely yeah yeah so if you don't a
lot of were like built we just outside
of outside of what's in the in the story
itself oh yeah I think there's a lot
there's a lot there's a lot of
tangential stuff going on you know and
some of it is like set up or mentioned
like I said tangentially in Tatia like I
set up I talked about the scarlet ocean
the scarlet sea and well the scarlet
ocean and what is in it so there's a
little section in Thalia where you have
the character Lucia telling the kids a
story about the island of Dustin bones
old Mariposa and what waits there and
then I've got like I've got if you look
at the map there's a lot of little hints
in the map a lot of different things
going on in a little map there's like
bring it up I can share your screen yeah
I uh yes should I should I can pull it
up let me see
just one second this is it actually true
I've gotta get a new rendering done of
this map by by and by another artist but
yeah this is the working map pull up a
map of myrath that's nor did you get a
name for my wrath did you just pull that
out of here
no wrath that I can't reveal it I there
is there is there some trickery going on
with the name morass oh there's a lot of
trickery trickery with names going on in
Thalia it is something that I am very
much playing around with and I'm aware
of like yeah all of that stuff I'm very
conscious of it all so yeah I am sharing
my screen now all right so yeah this is
a very base level view of the map so
over here you've got and that can use
the map piece though over here you've
got Rimmer castle and Villa rel where
Toddie was born and then here you've got
Elden which is where the entire first
book pretty much takes place right here
in Helden auswitch castle the Mandrake
pet pass and then of course the
mountains and the mines so um but yeah
there's a lot going on as you can see
outside of Elgin
it is a fully realized Kingdom so so
estin by Eston briar is mentioned I
think in yet is in the first book so
over here we've got the marble ocean
we've got Cinderella down here Hanul
Angeline Castle so here this is very
interesting you can maybe figure out
what happened here so we've got the
capital city sorrow to right here in
shadow palace and then the thought of
sea but then below but below the phyla
see we've got the Fallen Isle and at the
bottom of the Fallen Isle is more in
City
we'll destroyed City here and over here
we've got ash land and there's a little
crater right there so I won't say too
much about that just know that it exists
and over here we've got moon Isle and
Star City which will come into play at
some point as well
gone tera city over here and the gone
ter desert and you can see here the
capital city sorrow tus if kind of like
surrounded by these mountain ranges so
it's very difficult let's say if you
were gonna attack Sarah - so you'd have
to get across the mountains mmm or if
you want it if you and they can't really
be attacked from GaN terra because you'd
have to attack the GaN tip you'd have to
go through the GaN terra desert so yeah
and it's basically a wasteland so the
capital city is very much secluded to
protect it because of the mountain range
um and up here let's say we've got the
darkling seat a little image of a sea
monster there's rumors of monsters in
the darkling see just in case you're
wondering it's not really a sea it's
more it's more it's more of a giant lake
more of a giant lake but they called it
the darkling sea and what are the scale
here what is the scale yeah I'd have
after like really really figure out the
exact numbers on the scale but yeah this
is more of a mock-up map than more of a
like exactly like accurate 100% map
which is why I said I've got to have
like an actual map designer an artist
come in work on all the little details
and fix everything up yeah trouble like
George Martin did yeah have you seen
that video of him just talking about the
maps haha he had a lot of yeah when he
was around no I make stuff up for the
making up planet you gotta fill in all
the little discs yeah I was very careful
just to show you the kingdom of my wrath
at this point and basically the
surrounding areas because if this isn't
the entire known world obviously there's
other continents and whatnot but yeah
it's basic this is basically a mock-up
of Iraq well essentially someone says
maps are always cool I agree
yeah but I'm glad you're you know the
world-building is fun and all that stuff
but I'm glad your your focus is more on
the characters than it is absolutely
itself because uh I don't you don't want
to get get stuck in and I don't know I'm
personally I'm just not a huge fan of
Tolkien because it's all about world
buildings all about world building I'm
gonna take the map off
well actually I'm gonna leave the map up
one more second just to mention one
thing
pay attention guys just look at the
names on the map and just pay attention
to all names if you're into that sort of
thing you got the great forest over here
a crab city right here and Ketu City got
pirate up here the father sea free
tarath edge mount if you're into names
and like trying to put bits and pieces
together to like figure out hints and
figure out how things go together and
what things mean and then yeah this is
this is for you definitely all right so
I'm gonna take this off the screen so
you can put back up your art oops not a
huge fan of token unsubscribed I tried I
tried but you know what I tried after I
read the first three or four books of
Game of Thrones
oh yeah that's not gonna do it for you
then yeah yeah
cuz you know George George wrote for for
film and TV so he knows how to like just
hook the audience in right away see ya
for token it was all about designing a
world and then everything else the
narrative the characters everything was
secondary to that yeah I mean the guy
came up with the dang language yeah yeah
but george RR martin is all about the
characters and then the world is just
something that i like the way he
describes it cuz it's like he says i
imply a bunch of stuff so i don't have
to fill in all the details it's like i
just comply it and
it just seems bigger just by virtue of
in trying that's your work that's how it
works in the real world you know yeah
you don't get all the answers right off
the bat yeah and you won't either so
there's a lot of mysteries and Toddie
yet guys lots of mysteries and I'm it's
so funny because look in stream I was
streaming the other day and literally
someone figured out one of the mysteries
I didn't say anything insane I totally
figured it out like like on the spot and
I was like wow you guys are already
impressing me with your ability well I
guess I've got a lot of doom fans
enjoyed our Martin fans which are
exactly the type of people that would be
able to do that kind of stuff yeah yeah
yeah covers turning out so great and
you're like it's barely even started
barely I'm started yeah yeah before you
know Facebook and and all this crap
Twitter yeah they were the the Martin
fans were all on that on Westeros org
just just tearing into every little
detail you know mm-hmm trying to figure
out every possible you know they came up
with all the other theories and whatnot
and then then it kind of became it's in
its own industry when uh when it became
a HBO show yeah a whole like Game of
Thrones created it pulling it for so
many people
all right if it wasn't for Game of
Thrones my channel I don't my channel
wouldn't have got as big as it was I
know my channel grew a bunch because of
doom as well but like that's what I
started covering A Song of Ice and Fire
and then the again the game of their own
show and so yeah that was a huge boost
so when you've finally discovered Song
of Ice and Fire how many books were four
okay so around
I was done for yes I'm like that yeah
yeah around 2009 2009 alright yeah right
before I got the high school so and then
not a lot of them have come out since
one book yeah of to to have come out
since I started reading it and I started
reading it in 2001 dang yeah George's
taking his sweet time but that's okay
he's right and epic it's cool if I want
to rush him
someone says sounds very do nish dude I
am the Doudna SH dude so are you talking
about because I am the dammit dude is
the doom channel on youtube if you guys
are not subscribed to Quinn Quinn drop
your link in the chat someone said
didn't Tolkien create orcs and elves
that is true he in the way that they are
yeah absolutely
he created like the tall gorgeous wise
elf and then like the orc yeah and so at
that now they're just like fantasy
things yeah so it's just that's really
cool let him create an entire like types
of our character archetypes pencak
laughing so it's really impressed mm-hmm
that's why they call him the father of
the father of fantasy modern fantasy
yeah in the same way that someone like
Asimov is the father of modern modern
science science science fiction like if
you're doing anything with like an
empire in space
you got it from Asimov well he is the
template absolutely so yeah galactic
empire that was all him yeah I watched I
don't know if I watched the whole thing
you do you have a series on that or just
a single episode has them both I have
five or six Asimov videos on my channel
alright I know what yeah he did like
foundation
the you probably know some like iRobot
he did mm-hmm
bunch of robot stuff he created the
three will technically four laws of
robotics sure you've heard of that yeah
that guy who was first Lovecraft or
Tolkien huh
when did well token was the Lovecraft
night Lovelace cop is public domain
isn't it yeah at this what is look uh
public domain at this point isn't that
well I think so yeah
answer tokens not and Lovecraft died in
like 1929 or something like that he died
before he ever got famous that's the way
you want to go oh yeah right he died
before Twitter god bless him yeah I
don't know if he would have made Twitter
oh yeah I can talk about like Lovecraft
on I guess you guys will see this when
the campaign launches tomorrow but I do
have like a list of the influences for
Tatia or on the campaign patient I can
go through some of those so the first
influence for this book was Neil Gaiman
all right
so Neil Gaiman's Sandman it's like it's
like one of them it's like it's probably
at this point in my life like my
favorite graphic novel ever like just
period like that series so good it's so
like cerebral so deep like every single
like hey just like layered with and
waited with so much meaning and I just
love it and then it's also just well the
art varies but salmon overture in
particular is like just beautifully
drawn by JH Williams I love that book so
much yeah so that was like deeply
inspirational for just how much he cares
about a story and also Stephen King
Stephen King is like the father of like
poor basically at this point modern
horror like everybody knows who Stephen
King is yeah he likes oh the way Stephen
King can just like tap into like the
deep primal fear is that everybody has
in his books and it's just so terrifying
that was something that I also tried to
recreate for Tatia
and then also obviously Georgia Martin
of course like totally changed the
course of modern fantasy I bet he
noticed order martin and mainly what i
tried to emulate mostly from george will
not try to emulate but like what I took
from him was a the way his characters
seemed so grounded in reality it's not
black and white and then simultaneously
its existing within like a seamless
fantasy backdrop and that's what I
wanted to do just like create characters
and just like flip them in like a
fantasy world but then have the focus be
on the characters and have like the
fantasy world be the backdrop so yeah
and then HP Lovecraft obviously so there
would be no Stephen King without
Lovecraft and I'm pretty sure Martin's
work will be pretty different without
love draft because he definitely taps
into that like cosmic Solo cups is all
about like the deep terrors that are
awaiting in the blackness of space or
like hidden beneath the earth and
there's like a sense of unease and like
dark things to come like so it's always
a vocal like something like that and so
I was also trying to recreate that sense
for Tatia and then obviously if Nick
Herbert I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention Frank Herbert's been a Jesuit
which were also one of the key
influences for the dollars of Hakata as
well as Marion Zimmer Bradley is the
Mists of Avalon women of Avalon were
also a key influence for the doms of
Hakata and then finally l frank Baum and
Lewis Carroll who wrote The Wizard of Oz
and Alice in Wonderland so
a little bit bigger oh we lost to Quinn
we lost a Quinn we lost a Quinn now you
guys are seeing me cheat copying and I'm
all over Joe Kay says the whole great
character theme is considered in the new
fashion but actually all the great
mythological characters are gray I was
thinking about that because there are
you know there are people who are are
stalwart in their positions and I'm just
talking about in real life unfortunately
they're just not that many of us in real
life many of us that's that's me I must
all work there he is
but yeah I mean most people in real life
are our little fungible in their morals
so I don't even know when I dropped off
what was I saying when I dropped off
something about Lucy Carroll or
something oh damn
yeah so yeah so I was talking about oh I
was talking about el frank Baum and
Lewis Carroll who both wrote whoa Baum
wrote The Wizard of Oz The Wonderful
Wizard of Oz and Lewis Carroll wrote
Alice's of interest in Wonderland and so
both of these both of these stories are
basically about young girls that kind of
like stumble into like a magical reality
and basically nothing is as it seems so
nothing in one in Oz is as it seems and
certainly nothing in Wonderland is as it
seems so I just kept that in mind when I
was writing Katya and that's something
you should keep in mind as far as like
the influences so yeah and that's that
and that'll that's all on the campaign
page and you can read all that in detail
tomorrow when I want all the influence
you know what let's uh let's take a
sneak peek at the campaign page all
right and you pull it up um I can put it
on my screen and shimmer screen yeah
because otherwise I'm switching
from sharing screen things yeah let's go
get over to the screen but probably
easier for you to do it and then I'll
just I can do it I could not share
screen you can do it title you do
something refresh it about no quick
screen share so we are loading in and
you're seeing horribly slow you know you
guys are the first to get a sneak peek
at the Tatia campaign a snake it is
peakedness
still loading all right well well you'll
get a sneak peek in a minute any moment
yeah guys I'm on like a bad connection
right now which is why I'm only audio at
this point in time what's up with your
with your connection man I just don't
have one there is no internet here right
now and we're get it we were gonna work
on that on Monday that's as soon as we
can get anything done about it I'm like
aren't you launching your campaign
tomorrow yes I am but I'm gonna be doing
it all off my phone oh that's why I did
the test stream on Friday or whenever
that was which worked pretty well so
yeah but like now I'm on the computer so
it's like yeah but if you're on your
phone you can't have guests yes I can I
figure out how to do it really mm-hmm
wow that's new see if I host if I just
set it up to host from the computer I
can come in on my phone have the video
be for my phone and just be like a guest
but it will still be hosting it from the
computer and I can happen right
that's funny I tried that one time in it
I couldn't get it to work because my
daughter was in here mmm doing some
school stuff on my computer so I won't
this look Mike maybe you should just
pull it up preview all right ladies and
gentlemen there we go peaky preview II
look at that d'Italia
do you have the new video uploaded yes
it is up there you can play it if you
want yeah I don't think I have audio
shared on a lot they got a reshare Oh
God we're gonna show you guys a sneak
peek of the Tatia trailer damn wow you
guys are ready for this
the mother spear deep within the forest
stuff worth a got a switches work
there's strange magic under the cover of
night when Howard and Matthew Alden earn
you a new or a fantasy graphic novel a
young girl born into a noble family but
also into the hands of a manipulative
covenant with darkness as their cover
the witch's contact their dark works and
brought forth Tatia but we'll talk he'll
be theirs to bend to their will or have
they unknowingly through their own
hubris Unleashed something upon the
world which will finally fracture the
delicate balance that they have tried
desperately for centuries to maintain
Tanya of 1x or do now McCheese I'm not
gonna take an insult someone named Jacob
cheese oh yeah he's it's just trolling
me it's cheesy he's he's he's being a
little says bicker and make there's
usually the troll so we've got trolls in
abundance here so yeah I think it looks
cool I gave I gave it a thumbs up
oh yeah out of nothing tomorrow guys
also here's the campaign page yeah you
got a two and fifty dollar early bird
special that'll be all three hard covers
and three and click on each on what
happens just print expand it yeah yeah I
can't click any farther than that
because it'll take me to media that's it
yeah it's been a little window thing but
yeah they got what's the colors named
phenomenal colors to work on tell
Francois
both yo John Francois boyo yeah
Matthew Weldon sure found himself an
Asian crowdfunding outside of CP yeah
Matt Lee well but it's just so good he's
like you you're not gonna shut out like
me Matthew oldness just like that type
of talent it's just like always gonna be
recognized I feel like now um
victory it's it's 254 uh that bundle
thing yeah I think three unique
hardcovers and like three middle friends
but like we wanted a really low price
point for the paperback for like you can
get the digital copy for $10 and you can
get a paperback for fifteen yeah so we
want it like anybody to just be able to
get it and for Christ not to be like a
barrier or anything with that so but
then when you go to the sign paperback
it's 30 so it's a little bit more and
then the hardcover is 50 and then the
sign hardcover is 75 then we've got some
other bundles and deals and stuff like
that and then there's also some add-ons
like if you click on one of them and let
go to the checkout just pull it up and
you'll see there's a few add-ons that I
think this doesn't go to anything I need
to draft mode so those things are hidden
okay so yeah basically it's got um so
I've got like an audio script version
but you if you want you if you purchase
any other perks you can get that for $10
which is just me reading the script in
my voice which a lot of people are
asking for people of Quinns voice in I
don't mean a real railroad you but you
can be in the book Matthew well then
we'll draw you into the book and you
will get that page for a thousand bucks
and obviously a hardcover edition of the
book so you can get drawn into Tatia and
you'll get the original art page which
otherwise if the original art pages for
500 bucks only ten of these are going to
be available so that's a that's
awfully a lot of Quinn and Matt's big
fans will jump on that but look at that
three side haka solutely bucks that's
dope
mm-hmm so everybody got to get on over
there and if you have not already
subscribed to Quinn's page it's Quinn's
ideas is the signed edition limited when
it will be limited yes
it doesn't currently say it yet but I
think we're gonna limit that to like 200
maybe or I have to discuss that with you
oh to see what we should limit it to
yeah I think that's a good idea actually
maybe yeah also mega McCheese
Tonia would absolutely rexella mundo so
just that isn't yeah Victor says I'm not
getting this my guest Miller cover in
metal redo that man there's the trolling
that's when you're gonna you're gonna
have to get used to the trolls on my
channel so the troll ego leo leo I only
block the worst of them what yeah Victor
you're treading them too I'm perfectly
fine with bantering back and forth with
okay I'll have to jump on that signed
paperbacks version right off heck yeah
Sailor Moon has been around for decades
show some respect noob I I tried to
watch Sailor Moon because I wanted to do
some I don't know what your opinion is
on Sailor Moon but it was watch it as a
kid it was so bad I don't really
remember it she I mean look this is her
tagline is I'm gonna punish you
that sounds okay I suggested running
around saying she's gonna punish old men
well I know what this is all about like
come on yeah it kind of messed up yeah
all right so that's that's it you guys
got your sneak peek if you want to see
it again then go through and a lot of
great mad that's the thing we made sure
we had price ranges for everybody
absolutely digital copy ten bucks - to
being in the book for a thousand bucks
so whatever you're comfortable price
range is there's something for you that
was really important for me and for well
than all of us so that anybody can see
the book that's what we really wanted
more than anything that's right young
fiber said she could punish me whenever
all right what are you you're probably I
don't like it
Halon says I literally cannot wait it's
excited for you Quinn this is gonna be
sick thank you so much I know I'll do it
I'm I'm excited too and I'm very excited
I'm really hoping this just freakin
kills it everybody's excitement is
infectious you're doing good on these
eyes in oh here's the eyeball every time
I watch your draw I'm just like oh my
god that's like going I'm on with Dave
and dave just is quiet for like 20
minutes at a time just watching me draw
is like yeah man it's something about
just watching it come together and just
so well right in front of you it's like
slow TV they call it yeah yes dude there
was this thing on on Instagram
it had like 25,000 views and it was just
somebody is literally somebody doing
this with a pen just drawing the line I
mean it was a background but they're
just drawing these parallel lines like
disappear all they did on the video and
I'm like why does this have 25,000
houston's dude the stuff like paint
people literally videos of people just
mixing up paint getting millions of
views on YouTube not even thing just
mixing paint remember the the ghost
eating videos would bring that make
juices Tatia drawn and quartered that
might happen it's up to money yeah not
launched week when gets an order of ten
episodes in 20 years from HBO you're
like HBO yes do you want to do it no
those guys are Biff those guys are still
in the industry in 20 years I'm gonna be
so bad yeah I don't think they are cuz
man they they screw the pooch so hard
they lost their Star Wars okay great
yeah basically yeah they did they lost
his powers someone said can we ever see
the other continents in the world or
other characters in the world in the
same universe like I said earlier both
you can you can ruin the stream later
but we were showing up a map a little
bit earlier and basically there's just
my wrath in the map but I did mention
that there are other continents and as
far as other characters in the universe
same universe
absolutely I definitely have like like I
mentioned before there is a prequel in
mind the world lots in the mountain then
also a shorter comic about the island
maribo say in the scarlet ocean the
island of Destin bones which yeah I have
a lot of ideas about so yeah is there a
fold-out map in the book um that is
something that we will can thats
something that I want to do actually
have a map be in the book so that is
definitely something I considering but
it's not 100% very stretch goal type of
thing yeah it might be a stretch goal
yeah absolutely yeah cuz if this does
just crazy well you're gonna be able to
do all kinds of extra stuff which would
be amazing yeah I'd love to be able to
do that finally worked oh it did didn't
it
what it just like literally stalled it
didn't even like finish doing the
initial loading that it was trying to do
the first time ah whatever
give her some bald yeah
bald yeah but um it's a I really like
what you're doing with this cover yeah I
like that you're making it really
different from Matthews and and Kanaan's
yeah that is usually what I do but yeah
because people are gonna want some
variance so Kanaan's cover is like super
awesome in one way and then you've got
mattes that's just Todd yeah sitting by
the tree which is like awesome another
way they got yours oh he's sitting by
the tree one I thought he was doing the
other one well I told him to do the
sitting by the tree once since Canaan's
was more busy um I was like you do the
full-body sitting on the tree one okay
and then maybe we can like switch up the
back and change some things ending out
there cuz people really like the back of
that cover yeah I like that one too
Kataria beep freezer it depends on a few
things but I can't really give away a
deeps about it yeah that's always the
weird question you get when you create
so and so beautiful it's like another
fictional universe how am I supposed to
know yeah you should compare Tatia to
other witches and then I can give you a
better answer like him she I don't know
what's another witch Scarlet Witch
Scarlet Witch which is a mutant and
we've gotten well actually she does do
magic in the comics but in the in the
Marvel movies she's just telekinetic
basically at least I think I don't know
if they change them
in this hope it's some sort of magic in
the movie she's basically just
telekinetic and then she can like do
that weird like where she get got in
their minds at some point and made them
see stuff she's got the Jean Grey that's
Jean Grey Stella that's what that is
she went off around and she can like get
in me with Minds they turned her in Jean
Grey like in the comics she can like
it's magic it's like all the entire
universe in the car no no let's see how
do you versus universe oh that's a
Witcher so I haven't read The Witcher
books yet but I have played the game
it's a Tati oh I'd say Thalia UniFirst
magic I mean Tatia at full power level
would probably be a match probably
greater than univer she take her out a
uniform could she be - Yoda okay no Yoda
name you know about Darth Maul Darth
Maul
that's the guy with the spikes in his
face mmm-hmm I don't know I don't know
Star Wars like that I don't know
probably who kills him because I know
he's selling in like one movie so I
figure he's probably dead ultimately
obi-wan Kenobi Wow so yeah yeah yeah
Todd he could take out if obi-wan can do
magnet ah da good let's see all right
here's a question is Tanya a Mary Sue is
Tatia Amit absolutely not I don't think
so I did my best to give Talia like some
actual struggles especially later on she
does not always win stuff does not
always go right for Talia it is not like
she just fails upward no like yeah
there's some some bad things happen Mike
you ready so you've read at least doors
book all right let's see if fullscreen
they're kids
oh come closer to the camera
Oh green screen on see if your face
disappears shirt disappears
your face doesn't yeah it's like the
wrong color green oh right Thanks it
becomes the same color as a wall all
right all right so what does how do you
like potatoes what kind of question is
that
potatoes of course she likes potatoes
everybody likes potatoes okay these
innate are your versus Tatia yeah I mean
does Aria have the trampoline to jump
off of because I mean Aria killed the
night game like an unstoppable force of
nature so like I don't know if with the
trampoline though she's got to have her
tool her special tool and jump off of
out of nowhere so if she's got the
trampoline then Aria wait who's writing
it yeah oh yeah that's key yeah yeah
that's key maybe yeah if I'm writing I
don't know yeah that's like always my
answer I want someone else if the indie
are writing at then Aria just stabs bail
or she jumps off of a trampoline and
stabs bail or and mother Silas and kills
everybody and she's just the leader ever
so how many chapters do you have planned
chapters for Talia oh you mean like as
in volumes I'm a blue curry
I'm thinking I'm still thinking about
and then three basically own basically
what I was thinking is I'm pretty much
gonna have to make me
oh if we can hopefully get to the second
book then like it has to be like longer
ask you over longer than this one oh
yeah long 48 pages I think so
and in the third one as well I can make
them each leg a little bit longer at
like the second one and there would like
a little bit longer than the first one
that'd be great well and uh we were
talking about possibly if if it gets to
the point we can add pages to this one
pages absolutely which might be
fantastic yeah because there's enough
story there's enough story and but you
know we could add pages without adding
filler important part because your I
hate the idea of just adding random
pages to a story that's preexistent
because you're just you're just filling
pages at that point but there ain't
enough story in Tatia to actually add
pages and flesh out scenes and stuff
uh-huh so one says does toddy have
childbearing hips
you guys are these questions oh man
justjust just say yes and move on yes
yes yes she is voluptuous she's
everything you would imagine coke bottle
all of it okay going on after your
doesn't do a leather-bound edition of
all three volumes okay yeah yeah if we
could get to that that'd be great
and in fact that's what I was thinking
of doing anyway and then also something
cool that I was considering after all
three lines were released would be like
a novelization wish me to turn it all
into like a you know which will be
something I'd be totally interested in
doing but Talia rather be a bird who can
swim or a fish that can fly hmm
there's a bird that can swim yeah
there's a reason that I'm saying that
too so in Antalya there's a scene so I
have the character who's kind of like
the archetypal like storyteller
character named Lucia and she's always
telling stories to the kids and she
tells the story about this legendary
figure a woman who was created out of a
bushel of flowers by this wizard King
and he kept her in this castle and she
began to wither and wither and wither
and fade and all of her songs are sad
and eventually she fell in love with
someone else so he was gonna have her
burned but instead she walked into the
fire and out of the fire flew a bird of
night and so yeah Katya is definitely a
bird rather than a fish bird that can
swim rather than a fish that can fly I'm
sorry I just gave like an actual answer
to that BS question that works it works
well Katya go out cruising with a girl
of say oh the Sailor Moon no she
actively dislikes them they're not cool
enough for her all right of the
actresses throughout history who would
you have played Talia mm-hmm jeez that's
such a hard question these these types
of questions I'm never good at this cuz
like I don't remember actors names so
it's like I don't know I really don't
you're from seriously drawing a blank I
can't think of anybody hmm I don't know
I don't know I don't really think about
my characters in terms of like actress
oh you can play them and I don't really
understand even one like I'm like
reading a book and someone else's
question like what do you think yeah
you know what I'm like reading a book
and someone's like who do you think
should play so-and-so I never know I'm
just like I don't know whoever can play
it well right you know really if toddy
was ever being adapted it should be like
someone that nobody even knows that is
just a really good actress mm-hmm what
female character inspiration is used for
Tatia that is a great question that's a
great question
so more game Marion Zimmer Bradley the
Mists of Avalon was one of the key
character inspirations for Tatia
certainly so Morgaine well if you don't
know about mr. Babylon mr. Babylon is
basically a classic retelling of our
theory and myth but told from the
perspective of Morgan la Fey rather than
King Arthur so it's basically turning
the story on its head and saying oh she
wasn't this evil sorceress she would
internet not good it's me say mr.
Babylon yeah you were you're just
getting into Morgan la Fey and Mists of
Avalon yeah okay yeah so basically Mists
of Avalon it's a retelling of Arthur in
mist from the perspective of Morgan la
Fey and basically what she's thinking
she's turning on on its head and saying
actually Morgan la Fey wasn't like this
evil sorceress she was a misunderstood
woman that was put in a very difficult
position and having to you know deal
with Arthur when he refused to honor his
uh his pact with the women of Avalon so
it's like so she's kind of like I really
really liked that aspect of it and I
really really liked that character and
that was definitely one of the literary
influences for the character Tatia as
well as just like other various other
like female characters that I loved in
various bits of literature and
someone says Quinn Quinn no oh it's good
that disappeared a while ago but I am
back now like where hi Glenn
hey if you are on it come then please do
hit that subscribe button hit that Bell
for notifications and if you have not
subscribed to Quinn's channel is Quinn's
ideas please some mod put that up in the
chat so people can sub - Quinn's
absolutely huge channel what he's doing
here someone says I tie a channel who
knows someone says I hate it in this -
Devon that's cool you can hate it but
it's like that was one of that character
in particular was one of the influences
I don't think I've seen it or read it so
I'd like a better crew if you've if
you've seen like that I think they did a
miniseries at some point if you've seen
that and don't don't Bob that that's not
mr. Veblen that's just some miniseries
like I hate it when people watch like an
adaptation of something and then they're
like I hate this thing but that's not
the thing that's adaptation see exactly
ha ha ha you're free to hate the show
now but don't hate the books that's like
someone says that's like Merlyn being
the head of the white Council in The
Dresden flouse that's cool another thing
Marion Zimmer Bradley did with Miss
Babylon - is that she made Merlin a
title rather than a person who so it was
like there's multiple Merlin's
throughout that book so that's really
cool interesting
mmm-hmm what is Martin doesn't have a
title like a cleric or anything in that
well she ain't just such a random a
question because it's it's it's MIT
Smith yeah all the all the legends are
different they're all very but basically
he's just Merlin he's like though the
Wizards guy but the wizard guy keeps
blinking and this is horrible
I think wouldn't battery minutes I know
but this time I'm ah oh now you're on
your phone yeah because before I was
like I was casting my connection to the
computer and streaming from the computer
so I could use my microphone can't tell
my mic sounds different yeah yeah yeah
so it's gonna be like slightly lower
quality sound fine cool so yeah now I
can pull up the chat here so I can see
what the people are saying yeah but I'm
just like so excited for Tatia I'm so
excited for all the art that I'm saying
Matthew Weldon just did such an
incredible he did like just better than
I ever could have like even like wished
for or hoped for and then like Kanan and
then your cover is already looking
awesome
yeah I'm just very very excited for
tomorrow huh I am too this deaf man I
want this to be so freakin huge I want
you to blow the door in your room that's
uh oh that would be awesome
yeah
and then later someone said is Tatia is
it potty a ginger if so are you prepared
to see her cast as a black girl in a
hypothetical TV adaptation look Tatia is
not a gender and honestly Tatia is kind
of narrative Lee speaking this isn't
this just isn't even some BS I'm making
up but narrative Lee speaking Tatia is
kind of like a raceless character she
was created by witches who were like
from all various different places around
the place around the world and you can
see they all cut themselves and bleed
into the culture a little bit so oh it's
our grace so is she's she though witches
put their own essence or genetics into
her yep that was a part of the ritual
okay they each cut themselves and allow
a bit of its bleedin Josh if someone
says Canaan wasn't the choice I like his
style
Canaan oh my god I knew I want a cannon
to do art for Tatia
to do cover ever since I saw his art
literally late I was on a stream with
Mike and I was like can I hit him and be
one of my drivers months ago yep yeah as
soon as I brought up doing variant
covers Quinn's like can we get Kenan
yeah absolutely I think so yeah just
quick - mm-hmm I know he did it so quick
I was like wow that was quick it's cuz
it's digital man digital ghost so
looking off faster I'm doing this
digitally than if I was doing it
traditionally yeah man is it because you
can just like switch whatever you want
like super quick and just move it around
super quick it's because you can fix
stuff or you can copy and paste stuff
like I didn't have to do that I twice
you know I just copied and paste a
little oh yeah I see what you mean yeah
and then like when I when I get to doing
the hair I'll probably just do a couple
of these strands and then copy and paste
it underneath to give it volume behind
here and Wow Dixon tricks and tips make
things go faster and plus my hands are a
little ball the digital art techniques
yeah my hands are a little bit wrecked
from doing all the packing so yeah
easier on my hands that is otherwise
oops yeah being able to work in lane
audience all right do this first yeah
learning all these digital art
techniques I'm gonna be as good as mic
in like two weeks
oh man
Chelsea I don't know Mike I think your
fats are drugged traditionally says
jiminy
yeah that's not that's not the case I
did that Game of Thrones cover in two
hours which I mean I guess maybe I could
have done that traditionally but it it's
I can't do the way my hands were
yesterday or day before yesterday I
couldn't do it that way mm-hmm because
he the the control you need for the for
a brush and the control you need for a
stylus on a tablet or sort of a
different thing so oh this is a good
question will there be necromancy in the
book
well not necromancy exactly but there is
some don't get into sports I don't want
to spoil anything but there's some screw
stuff going on with like life and death
and body isn't so so I say oh yeah
so I will say but not neck hurt no not
necromancy specifically I can't wait to
see the whole or parts oh my god yeah
there are some great horror and Audia I
think and it's like I was like to the
point where like I was like I did some
things and Toddie where it was like I
was I went back and I thought about it
and I was like should I do this it's
this kind of like is this too much for
people I thought on some of the things
like there's some kind of gruesome
things to happen it's it's nothing over
the top but I feel like there are some
things that kind of if you're not
prepared for them can hit you you mean
the kid yeah there's there's some there
some there's some stuff yeah that and
then yeah other things but yeah that
let's see
this is tailored to Wheldon's art style
I do think he's a great fit for the
project
oh yeah like when Matthew Alden first
even just started showing me like his
layouts I was so excited because I was
just like wow like his vision for the
world and for Italian for this universe
was just like so just like amazing and
when I started seeing the inks I was
just like even more impressed and I
really do think it's because he's just
very passionate about the project which
is awesome I'm happy that he can be
passionate about the project as I am
because it is a partnership like as you
guys I don't know if you guys you notice
but Matthew welcome this is like a 50/50
thing like it's like Matthew Walden me
and him like both of our names gonna be
in the front of this so um because and I
wanted it to be like that because to me
like the art is just as important as the
words when it comes to a graphic novel
like I was going on and on about Sandman
overture and James Williams his art in
that book it takes Sandman to an entire
level so Neil Gaiman is already like a
master level like storytelling craftsman
and then you take out a comics artist
like JH Williams who's just like
breathtakingly amazing and pair those
two together and then you've got
something that's even more incredible
right so yeah I'm not like trying to
compare myself Neil Gaiman yeah he's
trying to make the Sandman issues that
didn't have good ordered so you know I'd
read him anyways but it was like you
know it's like you know there's that one
there's one volume of Sandman where it's
like a shape Shakespeare thing where
it's like he won and like all these
awards for and it puts Sandman on the
map but I read that volume and I'm just
like this is so bore ring and I don't
even know if it's because like I really
don't like Shakespeare I'm so sorry
but yeah I just wasn't interested in
seeing like Morpheus watch
a Midsummer Night's Dream just give me a
Sandman coming I don't need to watch The
Sandman watching Shakespeare die very
boring I dream in summer nights dream
I adopted that really way yeah the whole
story I always have stuff right at my
beck and call
so here nobody's I don't think anybody's
ever seen this stuff unless they bought
the digital comic and I don't think the
digital comic is even available anymore
but this was made for digital so oh wow
look at that I did a lot of background
swapping out and stuff so there's puck
so when did you do this when did this
come out oh I don't know No No maybe
eight or ten years ago
there's Midsummer Night's Dream to it
it's actually one of like Shakespeare's
like cooler stories in my opinion that
one in like Hamlet I can I kind of get
behind it was actually really fun the
internet about it was because I had to
go through you know seeing I seen I
really got to dissect what every line
means a lot of times when you're you're
you know reading or watching Shakespeare
a lot of it just goes past you because
it's it's written in Old English it's
not that easy to comprehend everything
but when you're sitting there dissecting
tattled four-panel what's going on it's
like I really got a new appreciation for
for uh for Shakespeare yeah yeah so
that's yeah cuz like Midsummer Night's
Dream is basically like a little fantasy
story it's basically like a fantasy
story it's like what what Gaiman did in
that volume of Sandman basically was
like he
and basically so you got Morpheus who's
basically the Lord of dreams all stories
come from him and he had given
Shakespeare this story and so
Shakespeare's like performing it with
his troupe in a field in front of like
the actual beings from the dream realm
or whatever so it's got like the actual
characters that the story is actually
inspired by like the mythological
figures show up to watch it and so
that's basically will have what's
happening I still found it just like
rather trite published it I don't even
remember the name of the publisher
others out
dang spot wrong play wrong play that's
what I do that was one of the ones that
I mentioned was like that's actually one
of the better Shakespeare ones and that
one actually has which isn't it double
double toil and trouble baby
in fact when I think when I was first
explaining Thalia and I was mentioning
it being like this dynamic between these
like witches and this King was kind of
like cursed by them I had a few people
mention Hamlet and be like oh it's kind
of like Hamlet almost but it's not
really inspired by Hamlet that's kind of
coincidental but yeah
well it's all inspired by Hamlet if you
go back far enough yeah in trouble you
know that that yeah that witchy
archetype was definitely like money or
another one Hercules Hercules please
yeah hot potato Orchestra stalls puck
will make amends yeah it's cool it's
cool cuz I'm pretty sure puck shows up
in that salmon going to like the actual
puck and he's like watching from the
back row or something like that
dang it yeah yeah what am I talking
about Macbeth Macbeth Macbeth this is
the one with witches a Hamlet all right
I say Hamlet now you get those two
confused I always get those two confused
for some reason absolutely getting which
eaten ah okay hmm six degrees of Hamlet
haha did you ever see um Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern are dead I don't think so
you know who Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern are no what is that from
from Hamlet they're his friends and they
get sent off I think too I forget why
they get sent off to like France or
something boring during the play of
Hamlet and then like you never hear from
them again and I believe it's because
they're killed and then there's a Tim
Roth and Gary Owen did a movie where
they play Rosencrantz and Guildenstern
and it's all about oh wow Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern are dead so what they
were doing
right they got EXO that is really funny
yeah it's really good today I don't
think I've ever actually like I don't
think I've ever actually read Hamlet or
that I don't even really actually know
what it's about it's about Dane lund
whatever you call that
Prince of the Danes who his mother his
father is murdered by his King is it his
brother who marries his mother and then
he know or he thinks he's just convinced
that that his father was not oh no his
father's ghost comes and tells him that
he was murdered
and so Hamlet's like trying to figure
out how to get revenge on his uncle
basically it's been a while okay yeah
his father dude they should I remember
to be or not to be
yeah it's like the famous one from
Hamlet yeah so when I was in high school
we read we read Romeo and Juliet and I'm
pretty sure I read Macbeth at some point
as well as well but I remember Romeo and
Juliet very vividly because I hated it I
hated every second of it I was like this
is the dumbest story I've ever read in
my life but then I've heard people say
to me that it's like supposed to be kind
of satirical and I'm just like is it
though I don't know because it's so dumb
it's like thirteen-year-old kids that
fall in love in three days and then kill
themselves because for no reason
basically it's just like a cake it's
romantic
no it's not like it's literally not
Titanic is more romantic
man yeah I'm just not a fan of Romeo and
Juliet all right so there's no roommate
absolutely what you're saying is you
have no Romeo and there is no there is
no Romeo and Dalia no no no no look I
hate look I hate kind of thrown in
romances I'm not saying I'm like totally
against romances mm-hmm but like I hate
I find so often in like a lot of [ __ ]
it's just like throw in a romance for no
reason even though it doesn't help the
story we just need one because I mean I
don't know not saying that Tati will
never have a romance I'm just saying
like I hate it when it's just like
thrown in there yeah shoot
certainly doesn't fit in this chapter no
not in this one this one is all about
exordium and so it's the exordium it's
the beginning by the way if you don't so
yeah I didn't even say that to everyone
people don't even know so book 1 this
first book is called exordium which
basically means the beginning the
commencement so it begins
so it's Tatia exordium logic tomorrow
yeah are you contacting your mailing
list does any no I'm using a service
called Constant Contact
okay we just designed the email I'm
gonna send out and I've got the links in
better setup with the secret perks for
the discounts and all that jazz and yeah
that's ready to go so um yeah I wasn't
ask you this yeah what time what time
should I punch like am I gonna do like a
midnight thing which would actually mean
like a few hours so I don't know about
that or am I gonna like so how should I
handle this I honestly don't know what
the best time is to launch a campaign I
would probably wrong what do it at
midnight tonight
that would be strokin about me the 14th
yeah except for that's not really a not
good time because usually yeah it people
that the purchasing dies down around 10
o'clock yeah so morning time no no I'm
gonna say maybe do it around from noon
to 3 noon so maybe instead we're talking
about like so noon EST probably might
work
sure why not mm-hmm okay Nick I've just
got his Lone Star woman to kill people
you heard it here oh crap that's awesome
mecha all week someone says I hope D and
D read it win I'm gonna try and rip it
off yeah this is our witch story
it's called Mahdia no it's Tatia Tatia
yeah all right any animals in Tatia is
showing intelligence not at this current
moment I mean I mean I guess you could
there's a thing with dogs in the second
book in the second one but it's not
really it's not like talking dogs or
anything like that but yeah because
Hakata the Triple Goddess is associated
with the cows and dogs and stuff of that
Tatiana
hahaha tah-dah Todd Aria Todd yeah yeah
so cool so what we're gonna have to do I
think it's like cuz I don't know when
that Kanan how soon Bell yeah it's gotta
have that Kanan color cover colored
should be like in the next day or so but
like just just say not final cover and
then you know it's good because when you
have the colors come in you can you can
do another email blast out and make do
announcements and stuff it's good to
have stuff to announce because you want
to keep in contact and constant contact
with your mailing list but you don't
want to just have nothing to say to them
you know you don't want to just spam
them you want to make sure you have some
important stuff to show them or tell
them so that'll be a good yeah all the
way totally other so the covers will be
up there in black and white at first and
then I can just be like hey so it looks
like colored now and I'll go and update
all the Photoshop things which will be
super easy to do yep and that's what
that's one thing yeah man and you can't
change your your tears your perks once
they then purchased but you can change
the graphic for them so I can change
what the graphic the graphic yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what I meant I can go
and update the graphics once I get like
the colored covers yeah any dragons are
the dragons in the world there are no
dragons there be no dragons I'm sorry to
disappoint
oh oh do you mean like what but monsters
though there's monsters yeah
there's there's rumors of Lake I mean I
showed you guys the map earlier there's
the darkling sea which is really just a
giant lake up in the north and there's
all sorts of rumors about stuff in there
and then there's also I was talking
about old matter boasts of the hidden
island and the Scarlet ocean there's all
sorts of rumored monsters there and it
also says in Tatia too when Lucia is
telling the story about drag year The
Fool
it says they might have faced faced sea
monsters in the Scarlet ocean at some
point so yeah monsters but not dragons
hmm would a gender bender be Tavia what
do you mean I don't you mean person todd
todd to you oh I get it
no just be Todd I guess it's like what
feel sounds like a woman named HOD
what's your name it would just be T ad
Todd Ted the gender bender version of
Todd yep in six months I'll launch a
campaign and it'll just be Tatia but
it'll be a guy instead and Todd same
book same book just drawings guy
everything will be the same just Todd
you draw another guy Matt well then
we'll stand you just don't like books
with female lead characters you're not
gonna like God's or yeah yeah
God swords gonna be epic if I can ever
get around to it
wait what Scott that's not shads look is
it not Oh what that's still secret oh
yeah yeah yeah
now my friends nibbles Smiggle flap is
making a book yeah anyway no godsword is
is I have this character who she's the
she's the daughter of an Ethiopian
princess and the and a Jewish
archaeologist and she's in actually at
one time it was going to be Iraq but I
think you might I might make it Egypt
but anyways they find this golden hilt
of a giant sword and and then like she's
in their tent one night and her name is
Eden and she's in her tent and a guy
comes in to take advantage of her and
this this hilt of a sword erupts into
flames and it becomes the god sword the
flaming sword that guarded the Garden of
Eden uh-huh from the Bible and it you
know it that becomes like it bonds with
her and it's kind of like a I don't know
Christian I get so cool I've been
tending to do that for a while
look it's the first hair oh yeah a
beautiful Mike Miller hair Mecca says I
don't like men writing women I want to
be able to hand a book to my son and
inspire him to be strong comics should
be aspirational well comics should be
entertaining yeah you're not I write
women in my comics some of the best
female characters I've ever read up and
written by men examine like vice versa
like male characters written by women I
don't I don't know what to tell you it's
just right a person don't even think
about writing a woman or a man
Chetta though what is it you take away
all accountability and I forget what
that phrase was someone's gotta know
it's with that Jack Nicholson quote from
what's the name of that movie
I think one with Tom Cruise no no no no
no this is a Ellen Ellen surname Barkin
Ellen Barkin and Jack Nicholson don't
know the one where he says you know you
make me want to be a better man as good
as it gets
there you go mm-hmm are there more races
like Tarija out there what do you mean
race is like Katya I mean Todd is just
she's not she's just a person so it's
not like oh no I mean like fantasy races
I don't I don't have like yeah I mean
there are there's like the to Lhasa who
are mentioned and for Maury
but like Talia is a human so is she
really though is she but I guess you'll
find out
is she truly human or is she like a
messed up lizard person wearing a human
skin well I didn't twist guys I mean the
whole is a person the Golem thing and I
mean I'm it's in the early pages so it's
not really spoiling a [ __ ] is she is she
like a human or she like a human
construct
where are you asking me that
is she a human where she like a human
construct yeah well I don't want to give
it away now
yeah I am yeah she's got she's got human
blood she is she is flesh and bone she
is a girl but it's about like the soul
really and that's all I can say that's
what makes her different all right two
separate covers no no no two separate
strands so there can't really tell now
cuz it just looks like it just looks
like a messed up creature with like
weird hair and when i okay oh wait yeah
okay yeah okay
yeah I like that looks apart and I love
those curls man girls with curls yep so
yeah what'd you think of that Tatia
trailer Mike pretty sick right
I like it yeah I feel like it's like
yeah you want oh you want to buy this
comic don't you I know what happens like
if I saw that like if I click though
that campaign page and it wasn't mine
being the person that I am I would buy
this book so that makes me feel good
that's what you want yeah
because I recognize my views on this may
be extreme your book looks great clean
thanks buddy
Cheyenne says that was her real face
haha just the I know all right now there
is some there's definitely some
glamouring stuff going on in Tatia as
far as like people with mother Silas in
particular but yeah just just heads up
whoops well this is really interesting
saying you do this right it's cheating
huh aren't cheating totally cheating man
I mean is it really though it's just
like a new way to do art because I still
couldn't do this anyway
I feel like Lego would be like a person
that can't do art can't just make this
so it's really just a requires skill to
do this right I don't know that is true
most people can't cheat this dude yeah
she looks like Rose McGowan from the
charm days I know you're a big fan I
mean I liked it I I'm more of a fan of
it now because it's like I liked it when
I was younger but like I very much
recognize that it's like not good it's
like not like great television no it's
the crappy 90s TV show but it did have
some cool elements and if you noticed
like the symbol that we've been using
for Tatia that triquetra Triple Goddess
symbol it's very similar to the one from
charmed actually the triquetra yeah it's
funny cuz I always thought that was a
symbol of the Trinity like the Holy
Trinity yeah wasn't that used in like no
Celtic or maybe not killed it but uh
well it's basically that symbol is
pretty much associated with like the
Triple Goddess hmm Nakata because it's
like three aspects mother maiden Crone
yeah so yeah that's another thing that's
cool so I do this in a second of volume
a second book there's a scene where
Tavia basically takes this drug thing
and so she comes into contact with the
three aspects of herself on the astral
plane basically in my kind of a
noncorporeal form and she's basically
communing with the three aspects of
herself which is really interesting it's
a really cool saying that I wrote up but
yeah she has you guys we'll see about
her poison water moment basically we
know what would Tatia be able to learn
the magic system of Westeros she
wouldn't even need it
honestly but I mean yeah why not did you
do to do to do
yeah Millis andhra would wouldn't be a
match for Tatia at full power now
Millis under would try her tricks but it
would not work can you check out front
as the shipment arrived well I have a
bunch of Mayors coming in supposed to
coming in be coming in today so I can
keep you know yeah they don't come in
I like being Italian because it because
it you know let's see let me just this
mecha McCheese so Rose McGowan is who
could play at a movie have you seen Rose
McGowan recently absolutely not
I said Rose McGowan like 15 years ago
but no but then also still not because
Rose McGowan is like way too pale also
but just like the face shape kind of
looks like those begun
so you're saying rose 10 not saying that
she's like hideous right she's too old
as well I next she's not she's not the
right age to be Tatia at this point
she's been beat up by life man you know
poor girl yeah she got into a really bad
car accident at one time and had to have
a bunch of surgery on her face that's
why she looks so different now yeah
no make toddy at the girl in split
who is the girl in split that was a
pretty good movie I enjoyed that movie
with James McAvoy where he's got all the
personalities yeah I only remember what
that girl looks like she had really
wide-set eyes that's like the big
feature dark dark wide-set eyes I think
mm-hmm I kind of a Glee remember what
she looks like maybe
yep Thalia has a bit of a tan so start
naming the actresses with tans like
ariana grande that's key and don't think
that she's too famous famous and too
petite to just too small look how big
Estonia my biggest aria I would imagine
she's like five eight five seven hello
she beat all for a girl slightly but
she's 16 I'm going to write a book
called Mecca table yeah I fully support
it Ellen but I'm gonna need that check
no someone says the only thing I know
Rose me going from is Quentin
Tarantino's grindhouse I was one she has
like the the ak-47 leg that's the roller
gun that's the ones
but digital audio audio look at that
weird strand of hair just like he's got
a weird mustache
come on that girls to the side she's got
very luscious lips
yeah those those bow lips
my wife has those lips so I just give me
everybody everyone says all my women
look like my wife that's probably why
those lips are great so yeah I was
talking I guess I could just talk about
Tavia a little bit more on that story
instead so I was talking about like how
I created like this fantasy world and I
was showing you guys the map and I were
talking about the world building and all
that stuff so like I said I wanted to
like create like this big have have the
story existing in like this bigger
fantasy world with like the Dark Lord
elements and like the kings and queens
and all this stuff but I wanted all of
that to kind of be in the background and
have the focus of the story be this very
contained story about like specifically
Tatia even though all this stuff was
happening around her so that's basically
what I was trying to create I and I
think I pretty much succeeded in that I
think this first this first book is
basically about Tatia and her handmaiden
becca and then figuring out the
mysteries and Elden and what's happening
in this place and there's there's
there's dark things happening in Eldon
and people are alive with stories of
demonic activity sorcery and things are
getting weird and
that's basically what the first one is
about in a nutshell of course there's a
lot of other elements that go into that
but that's the gist of it essentially
yeah with lots of little twists and
turns like in between oh he did I mean
did you get a yeah I did what is the
name of that bleeding fool get all the
bleeding fold bleeding I know it's a
comic book website that I told him about
the book so I wanted them I want to get
used to press I don't know I don't think
they email I'll check my emails I'll go
through everything again and after after
this dream but yeah we'll see maybe I'll
have to look at everything I've been
like since I woke up this morning I've
just been like literally working on the
campaign page I'm just like I literally
stopped to get on this stream well it's
about there anyways I want it to look
amazing Matthew Elgin was like but that
way his response to it was really great
he said it looked really really good so
makes me happy yeah it's really excited
about it okay I tried to make it look
good
I was looking at Billy Tucci's campaign
actually uh-huh and I was like his looks
really impressive just like the whole
look of the campaign page and I wouldn't
mind him look at least that good I guess
I don't know I think it looks good yeah
that's Baldy oh man it just works so
well let's load this technique with the
hair it really does work so well yeah
oops
yeah I can only imagine like the tedium
of having to draw like every single line
and it's I don't mind the tedium if I
have the time to do it because I'm weird
but it is we are little shy on deadline
time yeah yeah and then gogo snuck up on
me that's at that like we're gonna Cathy
Oh campaign in two weeks if you don't
lunch I think okay trying to lunch
already doing it we're already planning
on launching this month anyway but they
just like kind of kicked me in the butt
like you do it yeah yeah it's funny how
fast that six months went by just flew
by man absolutely straight incredible
like launching tomorrow and we'll see
how it does
yep I've just been promoting it like on
the YouTube community page people up and
singing aren't getting excited
commenting on it posting it on my
Facebook page and on Twitter
what's your was that what's your mailing
list up to what's my what mailing list
up to oh when is it up to like over
3,000 at this point nice we I think we
got it up but we got it up to like 31 I
think so you have you got about 30 100
people on the mailing list dude so yeah
it's pretty solid right yeah heck yeah
and we're back up to I didn't shed I
checked it earlier today and not we were
in launching soon we were back up to
number two because we have problems like
number four or something
oh yeah like Anna Star Wars girls
currently Karen oh really beating me
that's a day yeah with her secret
project that's coming out yeah as far as
launching soon she just she just
announced that today oh yeah so that's
well that's why number one think it body
would be number one if she had announced
getting yeah sorry after six months
you're no longer in the number it's
impressive that I'm still like I've
literally it's been like top three or
five like the longest consistently
pretty much which is awesome people have
shown interest consistently I haven't
even looked to see where Magus Evan is
you stop promoting I'm so busy doing
everything else that's like but I have
to yeah
July fourth so that's when it's coming
July 4th and already done with all the
art right yeah I mean I have some stuff
to fix but yeah pretty much
you drew it really quickly like a matter
of a couple weeks yeah I pretty pretty
much blew through that thing yeah I
never had so rosy in her okay so people
you are currently watching Mike Miller
draupati as hair ever strand strand by
strand
no a beautiful hair how do you do
between oh I just like say like how
thankful I am to have like such a
wonderful artist on this project it's a
it's a guy I constantly I'm just like
you Matt Kanan it's just like God I
could not ask for better 15 absolutely
fantastic
what was that it's a good team yeah it's
freaking great yeah I keep on to say how
excited I am to see how this does but
it's like so redundant at this point
yeah yeah yes yes yes we're excited very
excited yes yes yes you should come up
with some trading card goals oh yeah
maybe train cars are popular right I saw
those on a few campaigns yeah yeah for
uh for maybe bookmarks - oh yeah
bookmarks yeah yeah we're gonna have
which goals but we want to want to
launch and see before just like clapping
a bunch of stretch girls up there launch
and see how well it does the first
couple days and then we can send
reticles
with a better idea of what's achievable
yeah yeah so I'm like kind of anxious to
see how it does kind of nervous but
excited you know mm-hmm like you said I
don't know what else to say that's like
that's the main emotion that I'm feeling
right now
assignment anxiety anxious excitement
about to give birth
you have a good following and your
videos are good thanks a lot sim right
Simon on Simon on seven if that's about
right
can I get a Mike Miller cover Stein and
to kiss my perhaps about the kiss mark
her five yeah yeah
I just add after the highest tier I'm
gonna move over here start so I can't do
that with her hair here because I have
to kind of wing it
so oh wait yeah we sure our hair others
hey that's not hair that's that
so let's merge that merge those layers
look she's winking wait what happened
okay oh I see what I did
emerged everything together all right
okay Quinn no Cup Danny's back and I'm
back hello yes yes sorry that was
actually my mistake that time I closed
the browser for no reason no oh yeah yes
yet it can get pretty boring watching me
draw I'm gonna start doing some some
produced videos cuz my channels just
dying over here drawing all the strands
of hair for Todd yet each one of those
strands of hair is infused with magic
that's true that is canon now kidding so
yeah I mean I guess I could we haven't
really talked about the other characters
for Tatia at all I should I guess I can
talk about some of that so Talia's main
character and I guess in book one I
guess the i guess ii build character
would be the character Agata who is her
handmaiden that comes in at some point
and there's also Thomas Timothy Todd his
dad was kind of an idiot and a pushover
I
a Ella or hi Elia toddy is stepmother
and Ella her little sister and Damien
her little brother and then we've got
the town priest Teslin who comes in the
blade is through the douche and we've
also got shodhan the Lord Ashe maker who
shows up right at the end right at the
end and the ash makers are basically
wish hunters J is right at the end of
the first book
who else isn't idea we mentioned Teslin
there is low cig a little boy who plays
a pretty significant role in Thalia and
in fact what Lucic does in this first
volume of Tatia pretty much sets the
stage or everything that happens in all
of the other ones
it's like sense all of that out it's
totally it's very important but yeah so
yeah those are some of the characters
probably missing a few there's Marella
the latias cousin who shows up
oh yeah the witches yeah obviously
goddammit so there's mother Silas who is
basically mother Silas is the only coven
witch that you need to know about that
needs to be named right now even though
I do know who the other ones are she's
the only one that is named in this first
volume Katya and mother Silas is the
leader of the coven and she is very very
very very very manipulative and dead set
on the goal that she has in mind and she
is unwilling to let anything get in her
way anything she's willing to do almost
anything to do what she needs to do she
has the big cheese a huge vendetta
against Gideon who is the current king
with my wrath huge vendetta and you'll
find out more about why she hates him so
much in the second volume um so
basically what I told you about it is
that at some point the coven went to
Gideon for help they asked him to stop
you know kind of like persecuting the
worshippers of the old ways and kind of
like stop you know pushing this new
religion the divinity because it's like
hurting the Tawaf
and it's weakened
the barrier basically and he basically
tells in the screw off and that's part
of the reason that mother Silas hates
him but that's not the full reason
that's not the full picture there's
definitely more to that backstory not
exactly not exactly that's that's kind
of like it's part of the misdirection I
can't tell you what it is it's great
though it's great like I said I hate
shoehorn I hate shoehorn romances so
like I'm not gonna say I hate a shoehorn
romance in the dish you own or a man
said but yeah there are reasons there
are reasons which you but yeah romance
is the season for revenge perhaps
sometimes it is sometimes you need a
romance and like I said I'm not totally
against it it just has to be has to be a
right
someone says hi Quinn's Lee hello hello
Roscoe hair teared up Mike as Miller
strand know always they always want my
hair I think they want to make probably
Simeon says it's out tomorrow I thought
was next week town that's why yep it's
tomorrow Sunday it was noon
so it's noon Eastern Time wraiths elope
so it'll be a little bit earlier Pacific
time yeah so Wow by the time I wake up
it'll be up and going yeah so we will
see and send that list out and start
streaming and be like look guys it is
available did math confirm if he can be
here he did I don't know I don't know
we'll have to see I asked him several
times but I'll ask me again know how he
is with the DMS did you ask Keenan
yeah I know how he is I didn't ask Kanan
yeah I need to ask him and see if he can
come on yeah
someone says Quinn who are your literary
influences I actually went over earlier
in the stream all the specific
influences for Tatia I went over all of
them earlier on and basically I
mentioned Neil Gaiman and then
specifically what Marion Zimmer Bradley
did with the character Morgaine in the
midst of Avalon and I mentioned Stephen
King Lovecraft I mentioned Lewis Carroll
with Alice in Wonderland and balm with
The Wizard of Oz so there's a lot and
you'll be able to read all that in
detail on when the campaign launches
tomorrow it'll all be on the campaign
page so totally sometimes you got a
bribe mat with peanut butter that's true
if you want him to do something at a set
time mats peanut butter Jones is
legendary so don't seek understanding
I'm perfectly fine with Matt with Matt's
creative process if he continues to
produce art that is as good as the art
that he's been producing yeah actually
he's been on there he's been on a
pepperoni lasagna Jones
so really with Matt is always about some
sort of a food thing so it's like oh I'm
eating and sorry I can't you're like mad
I'll give you I'm gonna take away 10%
but I'm gonna give you a lifetime supply
of pepperoni lasagna he would do it it's
like deal Oh someone says Ted Williams
Meerut memory is sorrow and thorn those
books have been recommended to me so
much as Anna Song of Ice and Fire fan
because apparently Georgia Martin was
heavily influenced by that series but I
have not read it and yeah so but thanks
for the recommendation I have not read
it though someone says Quinn is
obviously short for Quinn's Lee actually
Quinn is short for Quinn Daria's Quinn
Trel yeah yeah
he's actually Quinn Quinn Quinn Quinn
beta it's true my name is Quinn Quinn
secret is revealed I'm a double Quinn
the first time ever first double Quinn
yeah yeah I'm not sure there's many
other double Quinn's in the world I
could really go QQ Howard if I want it
which would be cool actually and I might
start doing that Q Howard that sounds
cool yeah - q Howard yeah - Q someone
said it's like a Greek name yeah Quinn
Darius is very much like a Greek
sounding name Quinn Darius I know dude
um I told you that first I was like
that's cool that's like yeah I used to
be very embarrassed of my name I used to
be like weird and long but then now I'm
just like yeah Quinn days I actually
considered changing my YouTube channel
to just Quinn Daria's but I went with
coins ideas but yeah yeah people think
you were making it up yeah yeah yeah
bright it's your last yesterday my my
daughter was asking me she's just like
why would anybody name their kid Mike
like Mike is so common you know nowadays
yeah what - and it's like thanks a lot
yeah
Mike is a very common name and so it's
like days they I know so many people
named Dave it's like actually ridiculous
my roommates name is Dave like I know so
many people named Dave oh yeah I know a
few people named Mike - so weird
all right like you said common name it
was only the most common name for like
an entire generation
but you know why my mom there Mike and
my brother Tom was cuz she was uh she
was expecting to get divorced and he's
like so she was just like preparing
herself that if she had to get divorced
she wanted her kids to have names that
that if she had to take us back to Japan
that people could pronounce in Japan so
she named me Mike oh wow
which by the way Michael in Japanese
that's a girl's name and then Tommy
which i think is also a girl really yeah
so she named a spike in Tom Michael and
Thomas my dad it's an excellent plan
young five ever says Mike co2 no it
would be ma I K Oh Michael which is
literally one of her best friends
daughter's name Michael Michael Michael
Michael that's gonna be one of your
characters names now is that I also
noticed that in one there's one frame
and Tatia we're all deist looks just
like Edwin I don't know if Matt did that
on purpose where there was one frame
where it's like Edwin yeah I don't know
maybe I'm just seeing it myself but
there's one frame yeah one little panel
it says my why not make instead of my me
toad why not Mick Mick I don't think
there's an e in Japanese e or e Mak no
there's no if there's no oh man look at
those luscious
Tatia curls the curls of Tatia
comics exposed wants you to start all
over says what does Quinn's book about
and why should I buy it okay yeah well
Tatia is so Tanja is an epic or fantasy
story surrounding the title character
Tatia so she's basically caught in
between the machinations of like this my
nephew a manipulative very powerful
coven of witches and King Gideon who has
kind of a vendetta against like the old
ways and he's employed his ash makers to
stamp out all of the old pagan worship
worship of the Tawaf leaving offerings
to the gods of course and whatnot and so
basically in the background while I'm
telling this very like kind of contained
story about this girl who's being who's
created by this coven for a specific
purpose so in the background I've got
this bigger wider more more classic
fantasy tale being told that's not the
focus about bail or and his evil eye and
his form or either arising and invading
the barrier and invading the realm of a
cocktail but like I said that is the
tangential backdrop to the story that is
very much about this young girl this
character figuring out who she is
figuring out why she was created and
what the purpose of it is but this first
book this first volume and the story is
specifically about the town Eldon where
she is growing up and there's very
strange things starting to happen people
are going missing villagers are going
missing those been murders people are
acting strangely and there's a very
specific reason
and it's about Tatia uncovering her
power figuring it out and also yeah
that's what it's about
essentially that's what's going on it's
horror fantasy essentially there we go
yep that's my 60 second [ __ ] we haven't
broken it down or quinn hasn't actually
you're having Matt break it down right
oh yeah yeah the book yeah yeah as far
as a panel by panel yeah so we haven't
seen that yet but I did read the story
and it is good so you guys are gonna
enjoy it
Quinn is a good writer so don't worry
about that we have the combo of
excellent writing and excellent art
which is how you make excellent graphic
novels thanks for saying so Mike alright
and yes I do believe this is a good
story and I tried my very best not to
emulate anybody that's the one thing I
didn't want to do like I I I didn't want
to like sit down and be like I'm gonna
try and be like this writer or try and
tell this kind of story
I always knew for a really long time
that I wanted to tell a story about
which is specifically witches and so it
was just a matter of like figuring out
all of the elements and putting it all
together and figuring out which bits of
mythology I wanted to use so I ended up
taking as I said like a lot of different
mythology from all over the place like
there's some various bits of African
mythology going on there's a lot of
Celtic mythology Norse mythology's in
there classical mythology is in there
it's just it's just all in there and
it's all slightly altered and weaved
together for the purposes of my story so
it's not like I didn't take miss
directly I took them and changed them
pretty significantly to fit so you'll
recognize all sorts of names and kind of
like thematic elements of different
myths yeah Arya Tatia Tatia
deselect and mike is currently currently
drawing her hair to make her not bald
eeeh yeah we're not doing bald eeeh yeah
and do do sign up early for the the
mailing list which way through is
popping up there you will get a very
nice discount if you if you if you sign
up to the mailing list you will and
that's the only way you'll get that
discount so let me tell you about the
discounts so if you get all the mailing
list you can get 20% off you signed a
paper back of Tatia and you can also get
15% off the signed hardcover of tada yet
you get on the mailing list yeah but you
have to sign up if what campaign launch
is tomorrow at noon at noon EST your
time is running out yes yes yes get on
it guys grab it like you want it this
Tatia wear a dress for the whole book i
mean see here's the thing
see i I created Kataria as a character
very much rejects this whole noble lady
idea so she has her stepmother a Ella or
ie Lea how are you gonna pronounce it
who is very very beautiful very into the
proper lady she comes from a very
wealthy family in fact between her and
Timothy her family is actually the
wealthy one and I actually do mention
her father
Tamron in this series who is a good
friend of the King Gideon actually so
that'll come in at some point
but yeah so al is very much like the
lady the noble lady and she's always
like Patti a comb your hair Talia
putting a dress Tatia stand up straight
and Talia very much very much rejects
that she doesn't really care about like
having the neat dress or like having her
hair combed all the time she's very much
wild child and there's even a specific
line where al is saying she should be
married off now before her wildness
destroys her which has various
implications but yeah yeah so that's
that's that's to deal with that does she
wear pointy shoes I'm afraid this is not
the last apprentice by Joseph Delaney
and witches do not wear pointy shoes
weight issues Tatia witches don't wear
in fact mother silas in that opening
scene when you first see her spear foot
in the woods so there's not shoes
a man I guess in in the and with still
frame ups huh I said no shoes for you
yeah no shoes Victor says I'm not buying
this for my son well you know Victor not
everything is for your son not
everything is for everybody that's the
thing like this this story this is a
scary fantasy story well it's a fantasy
story with some pretty significant
horror elements I should say yeah so and
it is about a girl it's about a female
character so that's not good that's
whatever in fact most of the characters
in Tatia are female so yeah just a heads
up it's a coven of witches but I do have
there's there several male characters
like I said toddie is dad huh
you got warlocks war oh I was talking
about earlier about the the backs to one
of the back stories so when we build up
the map earlier I showed you Elden which
is where like the first volume basically
takes place pretty much in Elden
contained and in those mountains
surrounding Elden and in the before the
mines were mines there was a group of
people that have been named by history
as the warlocks of the mountain so in
those mountains
yeah so in those mountains back in the
day they gave offerings to bail or and
sacrificed to bail oh and it says it
gave them it gave them powers over
mortal men and over animals and over all
sorts of things but like it was it
wasn't a power that was meant for people
to have at least that's the way the
quote/unquote myth goes and so they were
destroyed at some point but that's the
myth inside of Tatia but I was thinking
that I could go I had plans on going
back and doing like a shorter comic at
some point telling what was really the
backstory of the warlocks of the
mountain which is like the daughters of
Kotsay they really just worship one of
the heavenly aspects Bay Lord they
worship the dark one while the daughters
of the kataka Kotsay worship piccante
yeah it was the light one which is
interesting just think about that a
little bit because of you if you look at
what the coven is doing and then you
juxtapose it against how I'm describing
the goddess Tecate and how she's
supposed to operate you can kind of see
some discrepancies and that actually
does come into play at some point but
yeah basically what I was saying is if
that went wrong but what I was doing by
creating that back story with the
warlocks of the mountain and saying that
you had these people that worship the
heavenly aspect at some point and then
it went bad and then I'm trying to make
you think about what's happening now in
the current story with like the
daughters Hakata worshipping a heavenly
aspect and creating Tatia is this gonna
go bad in the same way maybe maybe not
we'll see so that's what I'm what I'm
trying to evoke here but they are called
the warlocks of the mountain that does
not mean that they're all necessarily
guys even though yeah they're guys so
there are the you know so huh
there's are they still around okay let's
look like it's that but let's let's but
like yeah so as far as like mailed
practitioners of witchcraft
it's not like I'm not handling the terms
warlock and which necessarily the way
those terms are traditionally used like
traditionally like a warlock is just a
male witch and then a witch is like a
female same thing but here I'm kind of
using the term warlock to mean
a worshipper or practitioner of let
Baylor's
form of magic almost whereas a which is
somewhere that draws their magic from a
contact your you're not its own rules
and its own definitions absolutely yeah
that's what I'm doing in Lone Star my my
vampires don't necessarily fit every
every you know mythology of vampires you
know I might have my own science behind
my vampires mm-hmm yeah absolutely
I also want to say to you like in
Natalia since I was talking about the
the gender dynamics or whatever they do
make use of of men there are men that
work for the coven or involved with the
covenant their various different ways
but yeah but like the daughters of the
Conte are very much a matriarchal order
whereas like the I I guess I'll say this
the warlocks of the mound if they were
to still exist they their power has
greatly dwindled and they don't exist in
the same capacity that they once did and
that's also someone says like the kindly
man's on Gaiman yeah so the kindly man's
is I mean the kindly ones is a volume of
Sandman I think it's the last one I
think it's been his name that to Hansel
and Gretel show up to kill the witches
how would you predict by ending god I
gotta change everything now oh yeah yeah
change everything these guys are there
unicorns no unicorn I'm sorry to
disappoint but you can watch My Little
Pony if you want that is directed
towards me
a very strong argument for unicorns
being the because you know unicorns are
in the Bible and I have people who will
argue with a that unicorns didn't exist
and I'm like literally the Asian woolly
Rhino is a unicorn horn it's literally
the the Latin name for it is unicorn us
oh wow that's interesting yeah and if
you go to Marco Polo's description of a
unicorn
it's the Asian woolly Rhino it's like
the head like a Borla giant you know
horn and it's like it's you go through
the whole description there like he's
describing a frickin Asian woolly rhino
you know yeah so so people know how how
staunch I am about my unicorn faith and
so they it's kind of my channel so yeah
you still picture says I can't sign up
for some reason I'm not sure why that is
you should just be able to click on the
on the launch page and then like there's
like a little bar right there that says
sign up and type it in and just click
accept and it's like okay or whatever I
don't know might be a IndieGoGo
two-shoes it might be Victor Victor
unicorn is for life
that's right DJ oh yeah and they have
they have a frozen baby rhino so I don't
see why they can't clone them I don't
even know how that works with genetics
instead of using cloned goats they can
clone on freaking unicorn c'mon don't
they have to like sequence the DNA code
first though which like takes forever
yeah come on Mike - spread your
expertise on biomechanics I want you I
want mammoths I want unicorns
I want dinosaurs so welcome to Jurassic
Park right bring it bring it you know
there are certain parts of California
that looked just like Jurassic Park I've
noticed that like we were driving
through a forest before you get to like
that little babe part that's like
basically driving across the bay that
forest that jungle looks like Jurassic
Park seriously yeah where have you been
now that you've been here have you have
you gone up like Mendocino or San
Francisco or I've been I've been all
through the bay I've been a San
Francisco I haven't gone up to the lake
no but yeah did you step on any human
feces while you were in San Francisco I
did not I did not
thankfully look at Tatia I keep clicking
away and then coming back and then
seeing the work that's been done yeah I
actually merge these layers up so it's
dang man that is impressive
that's so funny like I
really did think about like hiring like
a choir to like
someone says the DNA code is damaged
similar creatures may not have similar
normal chromosomes at least with a goat
you can clone the chat muj police with a
goat clone you have a real go to
impregnate how do you know the DNA code
is damaged on that frozen woolly Rhino
have you done an average on the frozen
woolly Rhino to know for sure yeah
person way up in here on this tidy up
well Matt I'm glad you suggested to
Geographic novel to me like two years
ago it's been about two years at this
point agree yeah so it was like
literally on a stream that's like a you
ever considered doing a graphic novel
and I'm like oh I have a story that I've
been thinking about a little bit and now
we're about to lunch
it seems pretty surreal well if you make
a million bucks then yeah man I haven't
forgotten about you and it's been like
such such a blessing to have like you
helping me with this just like it would
have been so hard to do otherwise just
like as my first campaign not having
like a guidance or whatever no you know
really amazing
hopefully I can be on my own two feet in
the next campaign in Matthew Alden
dramas book yeah Tatia - but let's not
think about that yet let's get through
this first one one thing at a time man I
mean it's one I gotta go yeah let's see
when we talk about in the chat Aves
satanists Avenue sate satanís Ava
satanís alright just great great music
for horror movie and creepy and I can't
keep trying to knock everything off my
desk
I have the cat the kitty kitty kitty can
you just take your simple self man yeah
but I'm just
Tatia it's insane what else can I say
about it um you said you had the idea
what were you gonna do with the idea
prior to me
oh good see I think I was
conceptualizing it as either like uh
probably like a novel anything I was
thinking like a like just like an
average-sized novel like 400 pages or
something like that which is still
probably in the works because it's like
if we can once we put all three books I
can go back and still do the
novelization of it and put that out as
well but yeah that was the original
concept I think I was thinking about it
as a novel yeah but like I think that
the graphic novel just medium a comic
book medium it's just so amazing because
like you can tell there's definitely
something about opening up like there's
like a big hardcover graphic novel and
just seeing the page and just saying the
art immediately
versus just having to read the
description like there's something about
just having just beautiful full-page art
and then the words mm-hmm that just adds
something to it I think and I've gotten
a lot of joy it's definitely a different
experience reading a graphic novel
versus reading a book and I enjoy I knew
a lot and in fact recently I've always
read comics but recently as in like the
last four or five years I've been
reading way way way more graphic novels
and kind of less traditional books but I
won't say less probably just as many but
like I've been adding graphic novels to
the thing and when you suggested it to
me like so much just like popped up in
my head like so many things that I had
seen I was like why can't I do this like
I'm thinking about like Jodorowsky's
like the inkle and how much he does in
like the first 30 pages of that it's
just like what how do you do that in 30
pages so I was just like there so yeah
like I said just an incredibly versatile
medium and I feel I always hate it when
people say like oh it's a comic book and
they don't really like kind of a lot of
people like reject comic books
immediately I don't think Oh comment
book it's for kids it's like not that
deep it's basic but hello alan moore
this is a watchman from a thea sandman
there's so many examples of like Rick
Remender Lowe is one of my favorite
comic books it's so deep so beautiful
but yeah like I said tremendous
potential in the medium yeah and so what
was that said I knew you were a comic
fan yeah to you says love the artwork
thank you thank you
anybody here is new please do subscribe
if you are here and haven't subscribed
to Clinton ideas yet please get on over
there someone can drop the link in the
chat young people
remind him all weren't well done man he
should be here yeah well done well done
Weldon yeah where'd he go I knew he had
the other cover so I thought it'd be
cool if we could work on him at the same
time but that he's a flake yeah
Nixie says don't invoke Allen more Quinn
why not Eleanor is amazing only lawyers
great I think cuz not everybody's cup of
tea not he's great he's like a crazy old
chaos magician wizard guy and he doesn't
like he doesn't want you adapting his
story he's likely my story alone old
wizard pay no mind to that old wizard
yeah but like I was saying - I think he
might actually like the new Watchmen
show because I felt like that that
stayed on that wasn't like what they did
with like what DC did with like Doomsday
Clock Watchmen where it's like crapping
all over the old stuff and like trying
to bring it into like the back with
Batman and all of them like we don't
need them to be mixed in with all those
people but like what HBO did with
Lindelof that was good I liked it yeah I
like to to surprise they didn't they're
not doing a second one yeah oh man do
you think do you think you'd be even be
set up for a second one I hate it
honestly the end right at the end of it
is when I when I went it lost me right
at the end when she East the egg because
they had already been like anybody that
wants this power shouldn't have it and
then she then she eats the egg so it's
like she wanted the power what it coming
they kind of like defeated their own
thing right there at that point in my
opinion but other than that the show was
very very very good up until right at
the it Weldon is most likely on a
trampoline successful in sausage eating
peanut butter on a trampoline you need
the background for these stories not
found a trampoline
at a like someone was like leaving on
the side of their yard or whatever
really if stuff for the garbage or for
people to just take so he found this
trampoline and somehow he I mean he came
on the stream and he just seemed so out
of it I'm like what's going on he's like
oh you know I'll trampoline I kind of
hit my head on a thing I'm like you
sound like you have a card like no
everyone here thinks you have a
concussion like don't go - maybe you
should see a doctor
yeah Matthews Matthews really really
great man he's a great like as I've
gotten to know him over the course as
well as several several months he's a
really great guy really genuine very
very very very passionate about his art
and his craft and just very very
talented yeah like I don't know he's
just a great guy he is indeed he's a
tremendous goofball - so who likes free
trampolines
well who doesn't like free trampolines
had that's fair enough
hi honestly I probably would have taken
it - yeah man I don't know if I wouldn't
want to travel it's like we have a
trampoline like when those smaller ones
but I don't know how much jumping I know
we had a we had a big one in the
backyard when I was a kid man I got one
of the screens on it I think it's
awesome
I miss him well you can get yourself
another one soon but yeah whenever I get
an actual yard yeah and I can put things
in so you probably don't want to talk
about where you're looking but how's it
how's the house search going for the
apartments or whatever
it's going pretty good i we think we
know what we're gonna go for at this
point but yeah it's just the process of
weightings would be available and all
that jazz getting all of it going so and
it doesn't help that it's all happening
at the same time it's like my grab
you're not we're coming down just like
two things at once yeah but yeah that's
like man you're gonna need to get used
to totally yeah yep
I'm gradually getting more and more used
to it as I continue to become old
alright actually I think I'm gonna have
to run pretty soon to get um just to get
back to work on the campaign and jump
all right man
oops I really really really like what
you've done so far and I can't wait to
see like the finished thing and I might
jump back in later if you're still
streaming I don't know if you will be uh
yeah man you think man I'll be here all
right Keef dude all right he's up thank
guys for coming
and that was Quinn ladies and gentlemen
thank you for visiting layers yeah and
if you are new here Quinn Quinn does
come and hang out often so uh or has in
the past and we'll now that we're doing
the comic so please do subscribe if you
want to hang out for live streams and
whatnot do mostly mostly live streams on
my channel bring on the siege oh oh you
know what hold on a second all right let
me uh let me drop the link to the
Odyssey working
no she's busy oh hey look some more
people are showing the Lone Star's that
they got in I will be sharing those on
Twitter retweeting anybody else anybody
else goodness there's a bunch of posts
all right rock and roll where are we
where are we that was awkward what was
awkward Viktor you were awkward
Viktor that's so unlike you like and
share why can't I paste what happened oh
there we go
all right ooh that scared me bring in
siege to critique your work Mike ah I
sent her the link if she would like to
come in and critique my work then that's
fine let's get a good warp on here
good warp second bed into this hair
around the head
some people get their kicks stop in on a
dream right now that doesn't look right
all right I still don't get why someone
would down vote the stream there are
five of them now Oh Jeff you know you
know how it is how much would you charge
if I sent you might audio book with your
cover JIT and have you sign it oh yeah I
don't usually like to charge for stuff
like that but if I let one person do it
a bunch of people are gonna want to do
it so I don't know if that's a great
idea
but it's probably something I could I
could figure out I don't want to just
say no out of hand you know what I mean
we fill this spot here first
BAM whoops wrong one
yeah those two just lurk outside Mike's
house and when he goes for his walk jump
out it and brandishing the book at him
pay for the return shipping and tip him
for sure but obviously I think Mike
wants to be honest with you and you want
to be honest with him I do I do want to
be honest it's I've had people send
stuff to sign and you know sometimes I
get it back to him pretty quick but
sometimes it'll just sit there for the
longest time because I'm just busy so
you know there's a boy Isaac it's you a
burrito thing tempting me with my
burritos eh I see how you are now I see
what the plan is
funny mice bet that Star Wars girls
knocked Quinn's quit off the top of the
charts there what's going on there
BAM and merge those layers oh shoot I
forgot to copy that layer darn it I find
Mike's attempt to add hair amusing
alright alright keep the language a
little cleaner in that in Mike's chat
yeah oh this is a this it's just swear
free zone
thank you very much appreciate Mike side
of hair sucks for me before sending them
know what's going on with that Star Wars
girl oh she's launching another project
with dynamite I don't know what it is so
I I have no info for you on that front
but uh yeah she's launching a new
project with them and so she has it up
as a Oh what do they call that an
upcoming project sigh that what it is
you say what they call we didn't they
call it upcoming project
what time is Quinn's book launching
tomorrow 9 o'clock Pacific
o'clock Eastern Standard Time hope you
guys are excited about it I am I'm
excited about it for multiple reasons I
want to see Quinn and I want to see Matt
do really well and I all know look at
that
I screwed up I was like do this and then
get rid of this swirly thing I added
here and I want this to be part of my my
grander plan which Quinn is totally down
for which is getting getting larger
YouTube personalities larger channels to
start start making comic books and I
know Quinn was a writer so I saw that
right away that that was an opportunity
to have someone who knew the craft loves
comics to jump in and start and create
something for you know a new audience or
his audience frankly so as he's a step
one in my plan and he's totally down
with the plan so that is epic that is
not right
zoom no this is the one area invite star
wars girl Cecil Jon but keep an eye out
invite them to what invite them to what
to my plan
well God doesn't want to be part of my
plan your doesn't want to be part of the
plane look at that look at this is
shaping up look how her hair is shaping
up that is quinn is step one and mike's
villainous plan to conquer the world
it's not a villainous plan it's a
wonderful plan it's a plan born of love
love love is in the air love is in the
air I'm actually gonna leave that strand
this time that's another thing I want to
be howling let me do it oh no did you
want to do some random strands flapping
about that
my editor says overuse exclamation
points I like it a unibrow that's long
it's perfect that rebel curl look good
there but maybe too unruly for the
character no no no no that's that's what
you're not getting the character doesn't
like to be all nice and tidy and clean
she likes to be a bit of a rascal you
know so it works it works quite well
with the character this is going the
wrong way
she looked pretty tidy well alright give
this a little bit of a little bit of a
change here I don't want to all look
like I'm cutting and pasting everywhere
all the time
better quids a little bit stressed I
know right before I launch my campaigns
I was little little stressed not knowing
what's gonna happen you know
she knew crumbs on her hair why she hide
wands in that hair no I don't think this
isn't a Harry Potter kind of a story so
you're a wizard Harry want to fill this
place up right here because it's so
empty
oops
Hey whoops she's wearing white so it
would be hard to tell it's not white
she's not wearing white save this up a
little bit B make what you're talking
about
watch your [ __ ] Bob Wallace put you
talking about when a lot of hair looking
kind of white to me well it's all about
the colors isn't it the colors colors
colors colors ammonite made a walk in
psychopath talking king of the jungle
mr. gangstas stop
by correctly quick is my fuse red blue
live a damn other colors are choose
colors now two three four five six
little spots little spots let me and
oops I did it again I keep going that
donor March layers merge the layers huh
all that hair
did you already talked about C key C
sake me Chang having to apologize for
liking Candice Owens tweets no is that
what she liked I was wondering I saw I
saw that she likes something and then
she got hate mob for it but I didn't
know what she liked so I didn't pay it
much mine
but that's ridiculous nobody hate hate
mobs me for liking skinny jean aren't
for liking Kennesaw streets I do that
all the time let's see if we can do
these little squigglies sticking out
see how easy this stuff is when you're
doing it digital probably do something
about sting tone well I could leave it
to the colorist could just leave it all
up to the colorist
my accountant or a kind of hate bump
looks like good night but I like the
Mucca hair the most a cute choker hmm
that would be cute that's not part of
the character design so I say thee nay
let's do
some shading here thing I don't think my
freaking acting material is coming in
today they lied to me there be lies to
me
what mike has done I will redraw her
with all the stuff she is missing
dandruff comes on her and a new stop
you'll stop new kids and your ideas I
know I could just make a brush that
would make us look much easier that
would be just much easier
no show do anything in the background no
I guess thing hmm
you know I could do I could do a
background that is like that
set then I would have to do something
along the lines of yep where's my other
brushes no special effects brushes what
media bushes media brushes where is the
brush I flippin made ah fresh chips
first or import now I don't know where
my breasts man I had a brush that I made
for doing Criss crossing backgrounds but
now I don't know where it is
I'm not good at Photoshop simple so it
doesn't look busy pin drop pin drop what
I mean pin drop what you what is you
meaning but pin drop no I can just leave
it up with your color scared of it leave
it up for color I cannot plug it up plug
it up
I don't know I kind of like it like that
I need some opinions from the peanut
gallery here I'm just so bad at making
up my own line
sounds like a plan
does it though
it's great full moon storm clouds I need
to just clean some of this stuff up
clean it up clean it up make it nice doo
doo doo
how long has done here guys almost done
almost done yeah we're just gonna leave
it I'm gonna leave the backround open
and hope the colorist is uh is actually
they're using I think they're using the
colors from the the other guy so or so I
look forward to seeing what they do just
use the same colors for all three covers
that's a good idea
keep it clean keep it simple looks good
a fine young lass isn't she though I'm
just gonna being a little in on so I
should probably just stop save Mitch
let's flatten it up actually I'm gonna
delete that layer select in it save as
save as JPEG
I'll send that off to more detail tab
fill tab there's guys you have watched
it become a thing in real time how long
did that take 3 hours 23 minutes you do
some jewelry design some time ago I did
that's true I like the detail on the
earrings thank you thank you yeah so
there she is Miss Tonya don't forget
Tatia launches tomorrow on IndieGoGo
get over to out get to the link you can
sign up for a discount on garnet hold on
a second look at that so sloppy sloppy
you miss most of it sorry
oh oh okay cancel oh so I'm saving it's
already a it's already a JP all right
cool so I was fixing the final good
all rock and roll everybody liked it so
she's wearing a shoulder puffs but no
top she's wearing shoulder puffs it's
you haven't seen the design
uh-uh you missed a strand I know I was
thinking about doing like little
individual hairs but I don't know if how
mushy that would make her look I think
this looks okay right oh shoot I forgot
to do artists are some things in JPEG
I'm afraid do people do digital to save
time Mike does it to indulge his OCD
Josh all right I'm gonna get back to
trying to figure out how to how to pack
stuff without any packaging material so
I'll probably be sitting here printing
out print labels to get prepared for
Monday ah that's it ladies nermal Tatia
Tatia it's in the description links in
the description do get there and I get
to Magus 7 as well
manga 7 is going to be here go back max
boost max boost I get to mega 7 dot-com
sign up for that and I'll see you at
Aaron's now not me but enjoy thanks for
being here you have a good day and don't
forget to subscribe like subscribe share
do all that fun stuff
god bless you
we'll see you later